hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 9 hört zu und spricht nach
kannst du gut schwimmen kannst du gut
schwimmen ja ich kann gut schwimmen ja
ich kann gut schwimmen
nein ich kam nicht so gut schwimmen
nein ich kann nicht so gut schwimmen
nein ich kann gar nicht schwimmen
nein ich kann gar nicht schwimmen kannst
du gut kochen kannst du gut kochen ja
ich kann sehr gut kochen ja ich kann
sehr gut kochen
nein ich kann nicht gut kochen
nein ich kann nicht gut kochen kannst du
gitarre spielen kannst du gitarre
spielen
ja ich kann gitarre spielen
[Musik]
nein ich kann nicht gitarre spielen
kannst du auto fahren
kannst du auto fahren ja ich kann
autofahren
ja ich kann autofahren
nein ich kann nicht auto fahren
nein ich kann nicht auto fahren kannst
du gut fußball spielen kannst du gut
fußball spielen
ja ich kann sehr gut fußball spielen
nein ich kam nicht gut fußball spielen
nein ich kann nicht gut fußball spielen
im winter kann man snowboard fahren im
winter kann man snowboard fahren im
winter kann man schlitteln
[Musik]
im winter kann man schlitten im sommer
kann man wandern im sommer kann man
wandern
im sommer
kann man schwimmen im sommer kann man
schwimmen im sommer kann man velofahren
im sommer kann man velofahren dann
treffen wir uns dann treffen wir uns
uns um halb neun wir treffen uns um halb
neun
[Musik]
wo treffen wir uns wo treffen wir uns
wir treffen uns beim einkaufszentrum
na hast du lust auf basketball spielen
ja gute idee wann und wo
um halb
7 beim basketball platz
nein um halb sieben kann ich nicht
kommen
können wir uns um viertel nach sieben
treffen
ja um viertel nach sieben geht auch bis
dann
entschuldigung wie spät ist es
[Musik]
es ist 10 nach 3
wie viel uhr ist es es ist viertel vor
neun
wissen sie wie spät es ist
einen moment ich schaue nach
es ist halb vier können sie mir bitte
sagen wie spät es ist
es ist punkt 12 sag mal wie spät ist es
jetzt eigentlich schon
es ist zwanzig nach 7
ich bin
späth spät
spielen spielen sprechen sprechen
der sport der sport das spiel das spiel
springen springen der spiegel
der spiegel die verspätung die
verspätung
die
runde die stunde sterben sterben
streiten streiten
der stuhl der stuhl die stadt die stadt
der bleistift der bleistift der
zivilstand der zivilstand verstehen
verstehen
[Musik]